HAPPENS.
WE WILL BE HERE EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
DON'T MOVE.
SEAN CALLED AND WELCOME
"HANNITY."
NUTTY JERRY NADLER CIRCUS, HIS
SCHIFF SHOW IS STILL ONGOING.
GOING TO MONITOR THIS CHARADE
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL WILL JOIN US, HE'LL
TELL US IF THEY IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
THE SENATE, AND IMPORTANT
INFORMATION.
WE START NOVEMBER 8TH 2016,
62 MILLION AMERICANS, YOU, WE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE SHOCKED
THE WORLD.
YOU VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
HE WON A WHOPPING 304 ELECTORAL
VOTES, CARRIED OVER 30 STATES.
AND NOW DEMOCRATS ARE OFFICIALLY
TRYING TO FLUSH THAT FREE AND
FAIR ELECTION DOWN THE TOILET
BASED ON ZERO HIGH CRIMES, ZERO
MISDEMEANORS AND ZERO COUNTS OF
BRIBERY AND ZERO COUNTS OF
TREASON.
THIS WHAT WE GOT FOR THREE LONG
YEARS.
JUST TWO MADE UP BASELESS WEEK
BACKLESS CHARGES THAT WOULD
NEVER BE ALLOWED IN A COURT OF
WAR
LAW.
THIS BOILS DOWN TO ONE THE ONE
THING ONLY.
THAT IS THE LEFT, LIBERALS,
DEMOCRATS, SOCIALISTS, AND THEIR
MEDIA MOB FRIENDS, THEY THINK
THEY KNOW BETTER THAN WE, THE
PEOPLE THAT VOTED FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
THEY LOOK DOWN THEIR NOSES AT
US.
FINE.
THEY HAVE CONTEMPT FOR ALL
VALUES, OUR VIEWS, OUR LIFE AND
WAY OF LIFE, THEY HATE US, THEY
HATE OUR CHOICE FOR PRESIDENT.
SO FOR THREE YEARS, THREE LONG
YEARS, THEY HAVE DESPERATELY
TRIED TO UNDO AN ELECTION AND
IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP.
DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT, JUST
LISTEN TO THEIR DEAR FEARLESS
LEADER, SPEAKER PELOSI.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, THIS IS QUITE
REVEALING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ONE OF THE BIGGEST CRITICISMS
OF THE PROCESS HAS BEEN THE
SPEED AT WHICH THEY ARE MOVING.
SERIOUSLY, THOUGH.
>> IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR 22
MONTHS, OKAY?
TWO AND A HALF YEARS, ACTUALLY.
>> Sean: TWO AND A HALF YEARS?
SINCE HE GOT HERE.
RARE MOMENT OF TRUTH EVEN FOR
PELOSI.
WAY BACK IN JANUARY 2017, IT WAS
THE RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA HOAX
IN COORDINATION WITH A CORRUPT,
DECEITFUL, PROPAGANDA STATE RUN
SOCIALIST TV MOB IN THE MEDIA,
THE DEMOCRATS OF LIGHT OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN ABOUT TRUMP,
RUSSIA, COLLUSION.
THE ONLY COLLUSION WAS A DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR.
ADAM SCHIFF SAID HE HAS AMPLE
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
AND WE HAVE THE NADLER SHOW.
BY THE WAY, HE'S RUNNING HIS OWN
FULL SCHIFF SHOW AND HE SAID
THERE WAS COLLUSION IN PLAIN
SIGHT PIT OR ERIC SWALWELL.
A GREAT NEWSROOM FOR THE
PRESIDENCY, SAYING THE PRESIDENT
ACTS ON RUSSIA'S BEHALF.
MAYBE IT WAS HILLARY WHO BOUGHT
THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
NBC NEWS CHIEF CONSPIRACY
THEORIST BRASWELL AREA 51 RACHEL
MADDOW CALLING
TRUMP -- ARE YOU HEARING THIS?
THEY ARE ALL LYING TO THEIR
TEETH.
THEY HAVE SMEARED, SLANDERED,
THIS PARCHMENT FOR THIS IS WHO
THEY ARE, THIS IS WHAT THEY DO.
FOUR SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS,
ZERO RUSSIA COLLUSION.
ZERO.
ZIP.
HUGE BLOW TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY THOUGHT MUELLER WOULD GET
THEM TO THE FINISH LINE.
INSTEAD OF APOLOGIZING FOR YEARS
AND PUTTING THE COUNTRY THROUGH
HILL, THEY MOVED TO PLAN B.
LET'S MOVE THROUGH A NEW
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
AND NOW THE ELECTION FAST
APPROACHING.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING TO WASTE
NOW, THEY CAN'T RELY ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO DO THEIR
BIDDING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CANNOT RELY ON ELECTION TO
SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS WITH THE
PRESIDENT THREATENS THE VERY
INTEGRITY OF THAT ELECTION.
SO WITH A HEAVY HEART, WITH
CLEAR AND MINE THE DUTY TO OUR
COUNTRY, I SUPPORT THESE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT
THEM AS WELL.
>> Sean: DESPITE HIS HEAVY,
HEAVY, HEAVY, HARD OF NADLER,
HE'S RACING THIS THING ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE.
OF COURSE, PELOSI ANNOUNCED A
VOTE WILL TAKE PLACE NEXT WEEK.
FOR THE PAST TEN STRAIGHT HOURS,
AGAIN TODAY, DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
THEY'VE BEEN HOLDING IT ALL DAY,
ALL THE MARATHON, WE'VE GOT TO
GET IT DONE BEFORE CHRISTMAS HEA
GET IT DONE BEFORE CHRISTMAS HEI
GET IT DONE BEFORE CHRISTMAS HEG
GET IT DONE BEFORE CHRISTMAS HE.
WE LEARNED ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
NEW ALL DAY.
NO NEW FACTS PRESENTED.
KNOW WHEN THIS IS CALLED FOR
THERE'S ONLY BEEN ONE FACT
WITNESS.
EVERYTHING ELSE HEARSAY OR
OPINION.
INSTEAD, WE HEAR FROM A BUNCH OF
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS TOTALLY
DIVORCED FROM REALITY, LIVING IN
THE LAND OF RAGE AND HATRED AND
PSYCHOSIS AGAINST TRUMP.
ONE CONGRESSMAN THEM, COMPARING
THE IMPEACHMENT CHARADE TO THE
CIVIL RIGHTS AND SUFFRAGE
MOVEMENTS.
WOW, THEY THINK A LOT OF
THEMSELVES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SOMEWHAT CYNICALLY ARGUE THAT
THE IMPEACHMENT OF THIS
PRESIDENT WOULD FURTHER DIVIDE
AN ALREADY FRACTURED UNION.
SLAVERY ONCE DIVIDED THE NATION,
BUT EMANCIPATE
BUT EMANCIPATORS ROSE UP TO
CLARIFY ALL MEN ARE CREATED
EQUALLY.
WOMEN ROSE UP TO CLARIFY THAT
ALL VOICES MUST BE HEARD IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
JIM CROW ONCE DIVIDED THE
NATION, BUT CIVIL RIGHTS
CHAMPIONS ROSE UP TO CLARIFY
THAT ALL ARE ENTITLED TO EQUAL
PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW.
>> Sean: ALL LIES AND ALL
CONSPIRACY THEORIES HAVE TO BE
PEDDLED.
PER USUAL, DEMOCRATS CLEARLY
MORE INTERESTED IN THE HYPING OF
THEIR OWN WHICH TRIAL THAN
ACTUALLY GETTING TO ANY TRUTH OR
REAL JUSTICE BECAUSE THE TRUTH
IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS AMENDMENT STRIKES THE
REFERENCE TO JOE BIDEN AS THE
CENTER OF THE PROPOSED
INVESTIGATION AND REPLACES IT
WITH THE TRUE TOPIC OF THE
INVESTIGATION, BURISMA AND
HUNTER BIDEN.
OFFICERS FILED A NARCOTICS
OFFENSE REPORT LISTING ITEMS
SEIZED IN THE CAR INCLUDING A
PLASTIC BAG CONTAINING WHITE
POWDERY SUBSTANCE, A SECRET
SERVICE BUSINESS CARD, CREDIT
CARDS, AND HUNTER BIDEN'S
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
A LITTLE HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
BURISMA HIRED HUNTER BIDEN TO
RESOLVE THE INTERNATIONAL
DISPUTES WHEN HE COULD NOT
RESOLVE HIS OWN DISPUTE WITH
HERTZ RENTAL CAR OVER LEAVING
COCAINE AND A CRACK PIPE IN THE
CAR.
SPEWING COGNITION MATT GAETZ
ADVOCATING FOR AN AMENDMENT TO
THE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY INCLUDE
LANGUAGE ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN AND,
YES, ZERO EXPERIENCE IN THE
MILLIONS HE'S PAID.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
IT'S A QUID, A PRO, A QUO
IT'S A QUID, A PRO, A BUO
IT'S A QUID, A PRO, A BYE
HUNTER.
THAT'S THE EVIDENCE OF REAL
ABUSE OF POWER WHICH THEY
IGNORED.
THAT COMMITMENT ULTIMATELY
DEFEATED ALONGSIDE PARTY LINES
ALONGSIDE SEVERAL OTHER
AMENDMENTS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
THIS IS NOTHING BUT A PARTISAN
CIRCUS TO UNDO AN ELECTION.
RESIDENT SHRIMP WILL NEVER BE
CONVICTED IN THE SENATE.
SENATOR GRAHAM WILL DISMISS AND
SENATOR McCONNELL WILL DISMISS
THESE PHONY CHARGES.
ALL THE OTHER REPUBLICAN
SENATORS, LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
LOOK AT THE 31 DEMOCRATS FROM
THE DISTRICTS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CARRIED IN 2016.
SEE NANCY PELOSI?
SHE'S NOW MAKING ALL OF THOSE
LAWMAKERS WALK THE PLANK FOR
NOTHING.
SACRIFICING THOSE SEEDS TO
PLACATE A RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST.
SOME OF THESE LAWMAKERS ARE
STARTING TO WAFFLE AND BUCKLE
UNDER THE PRESSURE.
>> ARE YOU READY TO VOTE FOR
THEM?
>> WHAT I'M GOING TO DO NOW IS
WHAT I WAS ALWAYS TRYING TO DO
AS A CIA OFFICER.
SIT BY MYSELF WITH A FULL BODY